hallo mein name ist luca und ich stelle
euch heute eine ganz besondere minecraft
modifikation vor und zwar ist es die von
crafter modifikation diese
modifikationen wurde von einem zuschauer
von mir gemacht und jetzt öfters mal
unter irgendwelche videos runter
geschrieben und da ist mir dann
aufgefallen hey die ist gar nicht mal so
scheiße modifikation hat keinen tieferen
sinn also es gibt jetzt nichts
besonderes was die hinzufügt sondern sie
hängt halt mehr oder weniger einfach mit
meinem kanal zusammen das heißt wenn ihr
der bock drauf habt ihr findet den link
dazu einer beschreibung ich finds aber
cool desto was gemacht wird also probst
an dich bruder das kriegt auf jeden fall
von mir den daumen hoch der wir fahren
einfach mal mit den sachen hinzugefügt
werden und zwar sehen wir schon hier
ganz normales inventar wir gehen einer
seite weiter und wir sehen schon hier
der kernkraft teppich von crafter aber
naja hier finden wir dann die item fremy
gress traum triton conti wie dream i
live stream ii christel remis crystal
habe ich mir auch jeweils schon ins
inventar gezogen allerdings findet man
hier auf den seiten noch ein paar mehr
items und zwar findet man hier noch
spontan crafter damit man nichts bauen
kann und einen dreams tonnen benötigt
ban ich weiß nicht wo man den findet
tools findet man den was okay ja hier
da ist der dream stone dem benötigt man
nachher um das portal anzuzünden und
zwar fangen wir mal mit den einfachen
items andré migros ist in dieser anderen
dimensionen vorhanden was ich hab gesagt
aber das portal anzünden muss genauso
wie der traum krimis ton der conti weiß
ich nicht genau wie man sich gegen
trachtet oder allgemein auch wie man
sich vom grímsson kräften weil die
beschreibung war doch recht gering auf
der website aber ich kann euch einfach
mal zeigen nach dieser conti wie macht
und zwar egal wichtig davon setzte die
haben immer das gleiche bild quasi oder
komm einfach so ein paar ausschnitte aus
mein weg dieser schau da kommt einfach
so ein paar aus dass mein videos also
beispielsweise wo ich hier euch beim
romand fieldings zeige habe ich zeuge
gespielt habe ich max gemalt
beispielsweise der klepper bot und da
aber auch wieder in der commands folge
dann wieder von vorne also einfach ein
paar ausschnitte aus meinen videos dann
haben wir noch die dream ii ließ die
findet ihr auch nachher in der anderen
dimensionen die sind jetzt gerade noch
nicht transparent wenn ihr die nachher
in der anderen dimensionen geht dann
sind die dementsprechend auch
transparent dann haben wir noch den remy
christel robin finden wir auch in
anderen dimensionen wenn man den abort
bekommt man dream i crystals also das
sind diese teile hier das sind einfach
so ja ich glaube damit kann man so gar
nichts machen er sich sie jetzt ja auch
gerade keine items die irgendwie dream i
pixels oder wieso also hat man dann halt
einfach dann haben wir das ponton
treffer womit man ganz normal mit
spawnen kann und das witzige ist wenn
ich dann noch nie schlecht ich darauf
machen ist gerade in dem an landwirt
main kanal geöffnet
ich weiß nicht ich das rad steigen soll
aber das könnte jetzt wird der ball und
dann haben wir auch den krimis ton wie
man denen einsetzt oder so weiß ich zwar
aber ich weiß nicht genau wie man ihn
sich verhaftet allerdings benötigen wir
dafür jetzt erstmal wolle um in die
andere dimensionen zu kommen das heißt
wir uns hier ein bisschen wolle packen
hierfür wolle hin hier ein ganz normales
portal sowie sollen obsidian portal und
hier wieder drei runter und jetzt mit
dem dream ist einfach rechtsweg und
jetzt schon sieht diese schafe fakten
mich so ab wir haben hier dieses portal
wurde an die teile auch so ein bisschen
transparent sind und da kommt irgendwie
auch so komisch ich weiß gar nicht was
es ist was da rauskommt und wenn wir da
jetzt rein gehen weht ihr schon gehen
wir direkt in die andere welt dem ganz
viele contractors alder und das ist
jetzt quasi die dream dimension und wenn
ich jetzt langlauf seht ihr auch schon
mehr trauen griesdorn und nochmal die
migros und dieser dream eastern
verwandelt sich quasi in dieses krimis
sag ich mal wenn ich darüber fliege seht
ihr schon das verwandelt sich in diese
blauen steine
überall sind kontrabass und überall wenn
ich drauf clique bin ich quasi darauf
meinen kanal
hier ist auch die ganze zeit mops dh wir
haben hinten beispielsweise in skelett
wir haben hier je zombies und so weiter
und so fort
der wirt paket von einem zombie glaubt
im august sind das pussys die offenheit
tatsächlich alle weg nein jedenfalls
lasse die dream dimension der chip sind
ausdruck das ist auf jeden fall die drei
dimensionen muss dann noch so ein paar
andere items zu erkunden gibt und dort
kann man dann auch diese dream i
crystals finden und abbauen und kann
damit dann nichts weiter machen ein
glück dass bildet dann quasi auch schon
die komplette kontraste modifikationen
ich finde es ist zwar ein bisschen wenig
was hinzugefügt wurde
aber ich kann mir schon vorstellen wie
viel arbeit es ist wenn man einfach eine
modifikation entwickelt ich glaube die
beiden ein paar
hallo wenn es euch gefallen dann würde
ich mich über eine bewertung foyer
findet den download link dazu in der
beschreibung wenn ihr euch das ganze mal
selbst anschauen wollte es ist noch
verbesserungswürdig zum beispiel würde
ich mir dem verwendung für die die
christen mal sehr freuen dass wenn das
und dann und so und bleibt halt einfach
auch wenn auf der website ein paar mehr
informationen sind beispielsweise ein
paar bildchen wie ist das ganze
aufgebaut wie macht man sich überhaupt
ein portal weil ich mich da schon so ein
bisschen zurecht gerungen musste ich bin
heute wieder einen total aktiv dessen
realogis muss nicht zurecht rungen
gibt's dieses worte sagen bevor ich hier
noch weiter scheiße am frühen morgen
lager sehen wir uns in einem nächsten
video wieder tv das video soll kurz mir
leid